نفذ صحفي شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه وقفه
تضامنيه امام مبنى المحطه بالدوحه تعبيرا
عن التضامن مع الزملاء في الجزيره مباشر
بهاء الدين ابراهيم وزميليه هشام عبد
العزيز وربيع الشيخ المعتقلين في مصر ودعا
مشاركون في الوقفه الهيئات الدوليه
المعنيه بحريه الصحافه والمنظمات الحقوقيه
في العالم الى الوقوف مع زملاء المعتقلين
وتبني قضيتهم والمطالبه باطلاق سراحهم
فورا
هذا وقد اصدرت شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه
بيانا دعت فيه للافراج الفوري عن الصحفي
بهاء الدين ابراهيم وزميليها المعتقلين في
مصر وقالت شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه في
بيانها ان الزميل بهاء الدين ابراهيم
المنتج بقناه الجزيره مباشر يكمل اليوم
ثلاث سنوات في السجون المصريه واشارت الى
تعرض زميل بهاء الدين لانتهاكات قانونيه
مستمره منها الاخفاء القصري وتعذيب
بالكهرباء والحبس الانفرادي واعربت شبكه
الجزيره الاعلاميه عن قلقها الشديد على
سلامه زميل بهاء الدين ابراهيم وزميليه
هشام عبد العزيز وربيع الشيخ المحتجزين
كذلك دون محاكمه في زنا تفتقر لابسط شروط
الصحه والنظافه ودعت شبكه الجزيره
الاعلاميه في بيانها كل الهيئات المعنيه
بحريه الصحافه والمنظمات الحقوقيه في
العالم الى الوقوف مع الزميل بهاء الدين
ابراهيم وغيره من الصحفيين المسج في مصر
والمطالبه باطلاق سراحهم فورا